[Music] It's
completely different from what I said before.
The pride is amazing. If you live here, you'll have a
big family.
[Music]
Hey, whoa. [
Music]
Now, I can't clean the room. I'll
put up with the pride, the nest, and Polona, ​​but I can't handle the rats.  But, I ca
n't, I can't find another room.
Professor Bridget has taken the trouble to prepare one for me. I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't, can't
find another room. I'll
cover the mouse hole, so
leave Romantica to the cleaning.
I was listening to my story about how I'm good at cleaning Nene
Roman What's this? I'm going to use this place
[Music]
From
OG